[Music]  Lia's their chance that we could be  seeing the lovely Naomi shake it a  little bit you know what she told me she  started out as a dancer so you know very  possibly recently that was about ass she  demand I didn't demand no I I say ended  I studied dancing since I was three so  that's why I fight I mean that's better  catwalk rewarding has it been for you to  go from the modeling world and now  absolutely kickin booty in the acting  world then like for you to see her do so  phenomenal on your show fun so much fun  because she's come from such an  interesting such that's using life she  was tap from stuff to tap I was going to  say like as still one of the best most  well-known supermodels in the world when  you see newcomers like Kendall Jenner  and and Bella Hadid coming up do you  have any advice for them I embrace the  newcomers and I always will they want me  to teach them how to walk and I had the  time I do it  [Music]  you